[Music]
all prejudice is rooted in seeing a
group as other than ourselves ageism is
unique and uniquely weird in that that
other is us our own future older cells
it's rooted in this crazy idea that
somehow if we eat enough kale or don't
think about it we're not going to become
old when of course actually no one wants
to die young and we all aspire to
getting old and if we can become an old
person in training which is simply to
form a like just a little leap of the
imagination and they go and someday I'm
going to get old that older you can be
as far off on the horizon as you need it
to be but if you acknowledge that you of
course are someday going to get old and
yes it might not even all be so terrible
then you never get stuck on that hamster
wheel of aged denial you are more likely
to look at and listen to the older
people around you which is and make
friends of all ages which is so
important for people you know everywhere
on the age spectrum America is a deeply
consumer-driven Society and it deeply
influenced by popular culture and
neither of those are friends to aging if
you look at pop culture if you look at
advertising if you look at billboards
younger people are doing and selling all
the fun stuff older people never seem to
do anything but a few rich ones with
great hair get to go on cruises and
everyone else just stays home and takes
drugs and not the fun drugs either if
you're if an if a group is missing from
the popular conversation then we don't
notice its concerns and we're not awake
to it over 50% of workers over 50 leave
their jobs involuntarily they are either
fired or forced out there is this
massive growing body of workers and
we're really we're talking 50 and up
we're talking people with 20 or 30 more
years in which to support themselves
most of them no longer have traditional
pensions to support themselves so
they're thrown on their own well you
know ways they have to draw draw on
Social Security
earlier which means that they get less
out of the bucket and if you know if any
younger people are thinking well too bad
you had a really good run of it
two things to think about Social
Security can very easily be fixed with
very small changes like hello taxing
businesses at a higher rate
unlike Medicare which really is is a
huge snake pit and very complicated
effects but I hope there will be ton of
Social Security left for my children and
grandchildren and I think it's very easy
to make that happen
but also if older people can't support
themselves who is going to support us
you know you can't take us out and shoot
us even if you want to and I you know
the world is full of grandparents who
help their kids with with tuition with
childcare more resources have always
full flowed from older people to younger
people which seems entirely appropriate
to me so we really really need to be
careful about old versus young framing
in economic arenas or anywhere else
another place you hear old versus young
logic applied is the workforce if only
those old people would retire or get the
heck out of Dodge so we could have their
jobs when jobs are really few if the
only job in town is a barista at
Starbucks and a bunch of people are
competing for them that's true in the
narrowest sense you might have a 19 year
old and a 59 year old who both really
need that job but in general older and
younger workers do not compete for the
same jobs and more tellingly the amount
and nature of labor is not fixed
economists call this the fallacy of the
lump of Labor and it has been debunked
countless times otherwise when women
flooded into the workforce all these
guys would have been put out of work and
that's not the way it works or the
time-honored example for Marxism about
you know polish factory workers and you
know Irish factory workers competing
instead of organizing and striking to
have their employer pay them all a
decent wage prejudice does that it pits
us against each other in order to
maintain the status quo we are facing an
unparalleled set of challenges I'm
thinking in particular the health of the
planet older people and younger people
are going to have to collaborate to
solve these problems so when you hear
you know old versus young rhetoric
question it
[Music]